I'd like to introduce olaire here thank
you thanks thank you very much and
thanks everybody uh for coming
um
I'm here today to talk about publishing
Jupiter's notification I'm JJ Lair I'm
from positive yeah
it used to be called our studio
um so you may not have heard of
positives
so
um we're going to talk a lot about
Florida today but before we talk about
Porto I want to talk at a very high
level about Jupiter notebooks and what
is kind of special about them
um and for those of you who are users of
Jupiter notebooks or uh curious about
Jupiter notebooks uh passionate about
the imperative books I I really strongly
recommend you read this paper that was
written by Brian Granger and friendly
Perez who actually created Jupiter
notebooks and they talk about what's
special and distinctive about Jupiter
notebooks and of course as we all know
and we all probably benefit from all the
time uh no Jupiter notebooks are an
interactive Computing environment but
more than that they uh you know my
emphasis here uh help humans to think
and tell stories with code and data
Jupiter notebook's narrative and writing
are fundamental part of using the
Jupiter notebook and it really is
important in two Dimensions how many of
us have been writing about how we're
going to solve a problem that actually
affects how we solve the problem we're
writing about what we're going to do the
code actually affects what we do in the
code and how many of us have produced
outputted
visualization a model result various
figures
but there's additional context required
to understand what we produced and
that's the telling stories part
so reflecting a little more about this
idea of telling stories and telling the
whole stories some of you may have read
Edward tufty's pamphlet which is sort of
a takedown of the reductive style of
PowerPoint for for communicating about
data specifically one has a bunch of
examples in in the pamphlet one of them
is very specifically he actually has the
PowerPoint deck that was used to Green
Light the the ill-fated space shuttle
launch and some of the figures they
presented were very much presented in
isolation or some very very short you
know bullets on a slide and there's
actually quite a bit of important
context that was needed to understand
those figures so he's urging us to do
more when we communicate about data
um actually a podcast that I just heard
the other day was an interview with Bill
James how many of you here have heard of
Bill James
so you've probably heard of the movie
Moneyball and Bill James was actually
the person who kind of started the
revolution that led to Moneyball and
anyway
um he kind of invented sort of this idea
of deep data analysis of baseball and
sports but he's actually uh and as
things have gone on become kind of
disillusioned with where that movement
is gone because it's it's also become
quite productive where people are
obsessed with producing a single number
wins above replacement that fully
encapsulates the value of the baseball
player and when he used to write and and
do data analysis about baseball he had
quite a bit of narrative that went along
with it so this idea of narrative that
describe our assumptions constraints
qualifications that go along with the
data
visualizations that we present is really
fundamentally important and that's this
idea of telling stories computational
narratives telling stories about data
and that's kind of where Jupiter fits
and also you'll see in this talk
recorder fits so um before I get into
some of the specifics I want to
acknowledge there's quite a bit of
history in this um building tools to
help people with sophisticated technical
narratives interactive Computing weaving
those together that goes back to Tech
but it also goes back to notebooks
various implementations of markdown to
Jupiter itself and all these tools have
kind of I think really weaved together
themselves together in recent years to
create a very compelling environment for
computational narratives and
storytelling data so on to quarto
um I I spend most of my time now working
on Cordo but prior to that I worked on
the r Studio IDE along with with Joe
Chang who who's here I think and who you
probably heard some of you may have
heard get a talk about shiny for python
yesterday so I worked on our studio IDE
I worked on our markdown which was a
predecessor in a quarter that was R
specific and then I also worked on the r
interface to Python and the RNA a bunch
of other kind of machine learning
distributed computing libraries
and I I worked on our markdown for a
long time and I became very convinced
that the ideas behind it were sound and
valuable and customers were getting a
lot of value out of it but I was
discouraged by the fact that it was
really only a small slice of the people
that could benefit from it because it
was our specific and so I've actually
spent the last few years focusing on a
new project quarto which is an open
source project that's kind of a ground
up rewrite of some of the things we did
in our markdown but it's multi-language
and multi-vention
so we'll see this diagram a couple times
in this talk and we'll go into different
levels of depth about it but I want to
give you at a really really high level
what is quarto it's it's taking
computations and narrative from uh
Jupiter notebook to markdown plus the
code and whatever it produced goes into
that all goes into markdown and then is
transformed by a tool called Panda which
we'll talk about a little bit more it's
a markdown rendering engine into lots of
different types of output that's kind of
the core mechanic and we'll we'll drill
into more depth of these different steps
and what's important kind of how you can
customize it and hack the system
um so it the the sort of the core
roadmap for what I want to cover today's
talk I want to talk a little bit more
about the sort of supporting the idea of
computational narratives
um talk a little bit about the specific
requirements around technical
Communications uh this is distinct from
you know writing writing in Gmail or
writing a Google doc we deal with lots
of special types of content and assets
or media technical communication
this idea of semantic authoring where we
can public write once and publish in
many places a little bit more of getting
into notebooks the pros and cons and
different uses and ways they can be
melded
and tools and then a little more about
kind of how the system works and how you
can hack and extend it and make it do
exactly what you what you
so first um how do we support
computational narratives well the core
requirements is kind of what I just
described you've got to be able to
render executable content from Jupiter
you've got to be able to include these
kind of technical content types you've
got to be able to then take markdown and
turn into a lot of different output
formats
um this is you know Cordo does this but
it's it's not the first tool to do it in
fact uh there's a tool called MB convert
that's been around since the dawn of
Jupiter I think that does this sort of
thing and then there's also a couple
newer projects Jupiter book and Miss JS
that also do it so this talk I'm going
to focus very much kind of talk about
the tooling for computational errors
through the lens of Cordo but it's
important to know these other tools
exist they share a lot of the same
features and they're definitely all
worth all worth taking a look at
so how does quarter work uh you can see
here at the command line where we have a
notebook and we say quarto render the
notebook and that kicks off this
pipeline
um The Notebook may or may not have been
executed it could have been you've
already executed it interactively in
Jupiter lab or vs code or maybe a link
that you'd like to fully re-execute it
um I'll show you this in a minute we're
going to want to tailor the output that
we get out of the notebook that goes
into word or a website or a PDF or
presentation we do that with by
providing options uh and then what you
see at the top once we have our notebook
ready we just support our render and we
get the output that we're looking for
okay
um just a little bit about pandok before
I get into a bunch of examples panda is
really by itself an extraordinary piece
of software uh that we're kind of
building on top of and a lot of the
reason why we're able to do Implement a
lot of the features you're able to
implement and support all of the output
formats we're able to able to support it
was actually created almost not quite
almost 20 years ago but over 15 years
ago by John McFarland who's also one of
the folks who's behind common Mark
pandok has common Mark plus a lot of
extensions for technical writing
definition lists citations uh more
sophisticated tables things like that it
supports dozens of output formats and
I'll get into that later but just about
any output format you can name is
supported by pandok and most importantly
it's very extensible you can write
custom readers custom writers you can
filter you know the documents are read
into an AST that you can compute on so
it's a great foundation for building a
publishing platform okay so let's start
let's do a few examples and this example
will not be terribly impressive it's
something you've seen before we start
with the Jupiter notebook it's just
printing a few rows from a table and and
plotting and doing a plot and we take
that and we render it into a web page
you've seen this before again and we
convert lots of tools do this hopefully
we made the web page a little bit more
attractive than than you might usually
see but
um very straightforward transformation
you see all the code and you see all of
the on the okay so now let's talk about
the different ways you might tailor this
output with options
here we're actually going to add some
document level options we're going to
change the theme the sort of the theme
of the output the kind of overall CSS
template of the page we're going to
change the code highlighting style and
we're also going to say that we want to
allow viewers of the document readers of
the document to add comments to it using
hypothesis
so when we take this notebook and we
render it we see now the has a different
look the the code is indeed highlighted
using a different highlight style you
can see on the far right there's this
commenting bar that can be used for
people to to make comments on the
notebook so those are document level
options there's also cell level options
so I want to focus on the cell level
options but also note we've added some
different document level options here
we've said we'd actually like to hide
the code but make it folded so that
users can see if they want and we wanted
to add some tools for letting the users
kind of globally enable and disable
source code so that's different some
different Global options or document
options and then here we've said that we
want to provide a caption for our figure
and we want to provide a label so that
we can cross-reference it so now when we
render this you can see the code is
indeed collapsed folded there's this
code menu up here that will show you
demonstrate in a minute and you can see
that the finger does have a caption and
it's cross reference
all right uh open that code menu and say
show all code and you can see the code
cells uh open so this is these are just
examples there's actually believe it or
not hundreds of options that affect how
documents look and behave uh and a lot
dozens of options that affect how
computations are presented it's
extremely flexible and Powerful this is
just an example of sort of how you
interact with all those capabilities
um one of the things I want to emphasize
is that again you've seen enemy convert
making a web page from a notebook is not
particularly impressive get GitHub does
it too and you view a notebook of GitHub
but our goal is to go well well Beyond
Simple conversion and some of those
options I was showing you hinted that we
want you to produce professional
production quality output in whatever
format you need and complex outputs
outputs like books blogs websites
presentations uh really nice printed
documents all those things is our goal
with the two of them not just kicking
out the web page
um so so a couple examples of this here
I'm going to change the format to docx
and now when I render I'm going to get a
Word document I've got an option that
says I want to put my the two plots side
by side that would be a little Annoying
to do in word and this just sort of does
that automatically
so that's word uh we also have
um lots of lots of tooling for creating
PDFs here I'll show you we're gonna
we're gonna use a bibliography we're
going to say we actually want to put
citations in the margin uh because of
the Optimal Reading width uh is
somewhere around like 600 pixels and so
on a printed page actually you actually
have extra room in the margins to do
things we'll put the citations there and
then we'll also um we'll actually put
our figures in two columns and we'll use
the entire page again using the margins
you can see here I've got my Optimum
reading width I've got the citation the
margin and then I'm using the entire
width of the page for the plot so lots
of tools like this to make very tailored
readable output
um this presentation actually was
created with quarto we have a we can we
can create PowerPoint decks uh
Beamer decks and reveal.js decks this is
reveal.js this is an example of creative
slides and here I've said I want to put
a logo on my slides and include a slide
number in the upper right hand corner
here you can see now I've got a slide
that has the two plots the logo and the
numbers that are that are indicated by
the options this is just showing
um
a couple of quads you might actually be
trying to teach people about how to code
a plots that's a common application
you're sort of doing an internal
presentation trying to teach people how
to use an API in our library and so here
we're actually going to say Echo true
meaning please show the code and we
actually want to highlight specific line
numbers as we're talking through the
code the the audience can focus on the
right thing at the right time so here
you can see we've got Echo the code is
shown here just line four is highlighted
and then when I Advance the slide it's
going to highlight line five so this is
a tool for sort of doing technical
explanations of code and there's lots of
lots of other things related to code and
slides that support
um so far I've just shown you
single documents but quarter also has a
project system for uh aggregating
together in multiple documents and that
might be just um just sharing settings
and assets like CSS or it might be to
create a website or to create a book
um that's the project system so you can
see here I've got my quarter project
config file I say it's a website I
provide some website options and then I
say all the HTML that's in this website
should share this theme in these extra
CSS styles that's a really simple
project I'll show you some examples of
some more sophisticated projects this is
at the website for the fast AI deep
learning for coders course here you can
see there's a little more going on this
is pretty similar but here we've got
some Social Links we've got some uh
tailoring how links to GitHub work and
you can see now this is a full website
so this is
uh quite a few documents maybe 20 20
different documents linked to in the
sidebar you can also do link to them in
the nav bar and at the nav bar menu or
have a combination of those things so
this is a whole website done
with Porto written again in notebooks
here's a vlog similar we have some
social stuff Google analytics a little
bit of customizing the behavior of the
nav bar and when it collapses uh here
the homepage looks a little different it
sort of has tiles for all the different
blog posts so this is a Blog done as a
project and then an example of a book uh
here you can see again some some similar
options related to the get repo that
that is where the books develop but also
here now we've actually indicated the
chapters and the Order of the chapters
and then when we render the book you can
see we have a number of chapters I
actually have a numbered sections and
subsections and we actually can resolve
cross references across chapters
um so one of the interesting things
about books this book is a web-based
version of the book but obviously that's
not it's not super helpful if you
actually want to print a book or or you
know publish the book for a Kindle or
iBook users so books actually are
multi-format so we can actually uh you
can sort of a book you can think of a
book as a website that has extra
features but you can also take that from
the same notebooks and produce a PDF
book a word version of the book uh ePub
or ASCII doc then ask you Doc's actually
the format that's used by O'Reilly for
their book so there's a bunch of people
writing O'Reilly books using Porto and
then just taking advantage of the ASCII
doc output and then feeding that to our
Revenue
okay let's talk a little bit about some
of the specific requirements of
technical communication and how how
quarto supports those
um so what's different about technical
communication I I found this interesting
that Google Docs now supports code
blocks but that's as of like five months
ago so
um uh if you're doing technical
communication you definitely want to be
able to display code so my point here is
that tools like Microsoft Word and
Google Docs are not made for technical
communication
um sophisticated presentation of source
code citations and cross-references math
diagrams lots of things you want to do
that are not well supported by sort of
general purpose tools so how do we how
do we have support for these things I
showed you earlier you know some things
about code and customizing the
highlighting and making it hideable
we've got some other things if you're
trying to explain code where you've got
if you've got uh you know here's a code
block I want to explain these three
lines of code I've got a number next to
them and then I've got narrative
explaining each line of code below and
the way you do that
is you have your line of code you want
to bring narrative about and you have a
list below
and so on and so forth so that's code
annotation there's lots and lots of
tools for customizing how source code is
how source code is displayed diagrams
for those of you who haven't done this
it's actually a pretty cool way to
create diagrams you can actually write
diagrams in plain text this is a mermaid
diagram and in fact GitHub now supports
mermaid diagrams uh you know in GitHub
flavored markdown so when you're if you
want to read a diagram as part of a pull
request or or on an issue or in GitHub
Wiki you can use mermaid and then graph
is an older text-based diagramming
system that's still in pretty wide use
so this code here that I put in a
quarter document or a notebook results
in this diagram so for those of you
who've like struggled with Vizio or
tools like that to try to wrestle a
diagram into looking how you want this
is actually a significantly easier way
to do it equations of course lots of
times you you need to to use equations
in technical communication and here's a
couple examples of latex equations and
then those get automatically converted
you know that for word doc so to get
converted into mathml
um you know for the environments to
understand latex equation six Daily Tech
equations so those are supported for all
output format
um I showed you a little bit before
figures and cross references here I'm
going to show a figure that actually has
the caption and two there's a figure and
two sub figures and for to do that I
just say I've got a figure and I've got
two sub captions and when I when I
render this notebook you can see it's
got the figure but it's also got two sub
figures and there's a reference
referenceable individually
so and there's lots of ways to customize
figure panels you know you could have
two three you know three you can have
you know two on top of two and two on
top of one lots of different ways to
customize how figures are displayed
um I won't go in a lot of detail about
this but there's quite a quite deep
support for citations and bibliographies
and lots of different outputs Styles and
lots of different ways of presenting
citations so that's one of the most
significant kind of extensions to Common
Mark that pandok makes is the ability to
handle citations really well
um and call outs is another thing you
see a lot in in technical books and
Technical communication you can see
different types of call outs that you
know in some ways they they can amplify
the importance of content but sometimes
they can indicate to the user you don't
really need to read this unless you're a
specific type of reader and we support
call outs for for just about all the all
the most interesting output formats that
are targeted by quarter
um you I talked a little bit earlier
about using the margins because again
the kind of optimum reading width is not
800 or 1000 pixels
um and so you can actually put content
in the margin here's an example of a
notebook where we put an equation in the
margin or even a figure or a table of
the margin so it's useful because
there's ancillary information you think
the user might want to consult but you
don't want to burden the main narrative
with it it's very easy to stick things
into larger
uh and here's an example of a of a
visualization it's you know it's it's a
four plot panel it really wants to be as
wide as possible and so we're going to
say use the entire screen with a little
bit of inset so now I render this in the
web page no matter how big that web page
gets it's going to use the full screen
so this is like really let's let's
really make sure this visualization
seems large as possible
lots of different options for how to get
how you do
how do you use columns
um with figures and other things
all right a little bit more about this
idea of semantic authoring what do I
mean by semantic authoring well I'll
Define it a little bit by saying what is
literal authoring literal authoring is
writing or creating technical content or
report or analysis kind of in the native
format of a given medium so I'm writing
a dissertation latex I'm creating a
presentation with keynote I'm publishing
the Confluence Wiki and that's a lot of
the authoring that we do
but it has challenges I think one of the
biggest challenges especially when you
kind of like have notebooks or like
really high value technical content they
each have their own proprietary format
and it's quite awkward and time
consuming to take what you've got in a
notebook for example or in markdown and
repurpose it across many different
mediums
um these tools typically have
mostly non-existent support for the kind
of technical content that I just talked
about
um
they usually don't have any mechanism
for including Live code in its output so
usually you're ending up copying and
pasting and then when your notebook
changes your analysis changes you've got
to hopefully correctly update all your
outputs
um and that's what I've just alluded to
there's no real straightforward way to
sort of automate or reproduce
computationally derive content so the
idea I think is to move to this is
really what Jupiter notebooks do and
what markdown does move to semantic
authoring where you don't literally you
know double double click a word and say
this is full but you sort of write
textually this is a heading this is
italicized this is code this is a block
quote and then the the underlying
rendering engine can get that into the
right give it the right appearance in a
given Target format so again semantic
structure
[Music]
really important when we get into
talking about how the system can kind of
be hacked and customized
a panda parses the document into this
abstract syntax tree so the document is
something we can actually compute on we
can filter it we can change it we can
amend it we can do lots and lots of
things to the document after it's been
parsed into this abstract syntax but
that is not something you can do again
with all these literal output formats
but here since we've got the document in
this generic form it's very easy to
compute on many of the features in Porto
and many of the extensions that you
might want to use or write take
advantage of this this fast
so let's talk a little bit about how
that works with Jupiter as we said
before uh Jupiter execute cells creates
this markdown document goes into pandot
now once it's in pandok it actually
like like I described it's an AST and
you can write filters to transform the
AST again that's how we implemented many
of the features in Porto cross
references code folding layout all kind
of computing on this AST and you can do
the same thing
um and then the final output that's
rendered from the NST later on I've got
an example of doing that with python
um but pandok itself the power of having
having your documents in this in this
generic form is that it now can create
dozens of formats I'm not showing you
all the formats that pandok has these
are some of them uh there's this
conventional document formats
presentation formats many different
varieties of markdown
um and Wiki formats other formats you
may or may not have heard of but
actually are end up being important in
different contexts so it's an incredibly
powerful and flexible system and you can
even write custom writers to support
systems that that it doesn't itself
natively understand
um an example of this these are some
things that we added to pandok
um so Hugo you probably many of you are
familiar with that's a very popular tool
for building websites it uses its own uh
version of markdown based on a library
called goldmark Dr sewers is another
product that is used to create also
websites that uses its own flavor of
markdown MDX markdown where the each
markdown page is actually like a react
application uh Confluence you've
probably heard of it has its own XML
format and I talked about ASCII doc
earlier none of these are actually
supported natively by pandok but we
extended pandok to kind of be able to
Target these so if you if your
organization uses Hugo to publish
content and you have a notebook you can
now you know with format Hugo take that
notebook turn it into markdown and then
have it work within a Hugo website
similarly with docosaurus I've got the
same notebook and I write and the X
markdown which is the form of markdown
understood by docosaurus and now my
notebook shows up in a dot in the in the
dinosaurs website
similarly Confluence lots of
organizations use confluences as a core
knowledge management tool it'd be great
if we could push our notebooks up into
Confluence we wrote an extension to
pandok that takes that AST and
transforms it into native Confluence XML
so the same notebook now just shows up
as a Confluence page inside of
Confluence Wiki and I talked before
about using
ASCII doc to publish books with O'Reilly
okay I want to talk a little bit about
just Jupiter notebooks and I think you
know people have different opinions
about notebooks you've probably seen or
heard of maybe even attended uh Joel
Brews talk I don't like notebooks from
Jupiter's Cup 2018 or Jeremy Howard's
response I like notebooks
a lot of controversy about notebooks a
lot of hate a lot of love
um and I think I think the most
important thing to recognize is
for all the things they do well and
don't do well they are really at the
corner of the realm they they they
Define a standard container for code
output and related narrative that that
you can compute on and that is really
really powerful the fact that a notebook
can be published to GitHub or it can be
published to co-lab and interacted with
it can be authored by lots of different
tools
it's also a source of content for
embedding in other documents so
notebooks are very convenient for a lot
of things uh and I think they're they're
really important thing to build around
when we think about tools for publishing
uh data and data science
um I talked about as an authoring tool
it's a rebel with embedded narrative
that's awesome for this idea of of
thinking and telling stories with data
lots of different notebook authoring
tools are available and in all the file
formats are you know completely
compatible
now for those of you who don't like the
idea of authoring a big Json file that's
kind of one of the biggest complaints
about notebooks is wow how do I dip them
and it's really gross that it's all what
a Json file when it's I just got code
why is it why is it in this big
monolithic Json file you might not know
that there's a package called jupitex
which actually has
not one not two not three but ten
different plain text formats to
represent notebooks some based on
markdown some based on just a python
script that has special comments in it
so you can still use Jupiter and Jupiter
notebooks even in sort of a plain text
workflow Gordo has its own kind of
variation of that this is the qmd or the
pure markdown representation of the
notebook that we've been showing for the
whole talk the Apollo Penguins notebook
and you can see it has uh the metadata
and options it has code chunks it has
markdown
another coach on Cell options all the
same things you saw in Jupiter just in a
text file
and we have a vs code extension and you
can use to it gives you you know some of
the similar affordances that you would
expect in a notebook like being able to
run a cell or run cells above or run the
next cell or have code completion and
things like that so I think it's
important when we talk about notebooks
to think about it as kind of an
ecosystem and a standard container and
there's lots of different ways to author
for that and and work with that that
aren't tied to the sort of the
traditional iPhone B format
um and there's another scenario which
which I think is really interesting
where you you you you you
have a notebook that has a bunch of
computations and it maybe has the
results of uh uh it has predictions or
it has figures or it has tables and you
want to use that in other documents but
still not lose the connection back to
the original notebook and here's an
example of a notebook that will not
actually be published this notebook will
not be the main document that's
published but rather its outputs will be
embedded in another document you can see
here this embed short code
um so here's a qmd document it's got
narrative and it's got this embed which
says please embed a cell from an
external notebook right here when you do
that and then publish it it retains the
connection to the notebook so you can
see I've published this document but
there are no there are sort of source
notebooks behind it that you can link to
and here you can see for this particular
cell there's a source L for this figure
that you can go look at so here you may
want to for decision makers present a
narrative and figures but then you want
people to be able to go inspect the code
when you click that link you end up
navigating into the notebook View and
here you can see the code and all the
narrative that's in the notebook or even
download The Notebook if you want to run
it and inspect it locally
um we're actually working with some of
those other projects I mentioned earlier
Jupiter book Miss Js
uh with uh Sloan and agu kind of trying
to define a standard to let notebooks be
a standard part of the scientific record
let them be participate in peer review
don't lose like preserve them as Source
materials all the way through the
process and actually have that the code
and the notebooks be included in
archives so we're very excited about
that
okay a little bit uh to finish up about
how the system works and how you can
kind of customize and hack the system
um
a little bit first about how we
interface with Jupiter kernels we
execute code cells using Jupiter all
Jupiter kernels are supported I would
say that Python and Julia are the most
widely used and they have probably the
best the best tooling but I've seen
people use the C kernel The Bash kernel
the APL kernel and the SAS kernel lots
of different kernels
um that I've seen people use with Porto
um and one of the things we do is we
want the working with these documents to
be very interactive so we keep the
kernels alive for for up to five minutes
across renders because the startup time
can be long especially for Julia it can
be like 30 seconds so we kind of keep
the kernel alive so it's as fast and
responsive it's also important to note
Jupiter is not the only execution engine
we support
um we all the the execution engine part
of quarto is actually extensible we
support the Knitter engine for
compatibility with our markdown
documents and we can add other images in
the future so kind of all the investment
we're making in markdown and pandok and
Publishing outputs is works with Jupiter
now but if there are other interesting
execution engines that come along in the
future we can plug into those as well
um in terms of cell execution you you do
want to think about how expensive it is
to render to render notebooks or render
cells
If You author an ipin B you can control
exactly when execution occurs you can
cash results in the notebook you can you
know rerun all the sales or not rerun
all the cells If You author in text mode
it's going to re-execute this all the
cells that I'm going to render in order
but there are a couple I will get in the
details on these there are a couple of
caching expenditures available to make
that more reasonable so it's really
um kind of use whichever uh execution
model and caching strategy makes the
most sense for your for your project
there's a lot of ways to customize it
filters are really important part of the
system filters essentially are how we
Implement all the Porto features the the
document AST comes in before it goes for
final rendering and now the filter gets
a hold of it and it can do anything you
can generate content it can remove
content it can amend content you can add
formatting or move formatting lots of
different things can be done in filters
so I want to give you a really simple
python example here there's a library
called Pam flute we're rendering a
notebook and we've said please run this
filter when you render The Notebook you
can see this is the Full Source Code of
the filter and really the main thing
that's happening it's a really trivial
filter this is kind of the only code
that really matters here which is if you
find a header and it's less than level
six increase it so it's just saying
increase all the heavy Levels by one
again the very trivial example but you
can do very very powerful things with
filters
like all this stuff many of the features
of Porto implemented with filters
um and
um that's that's how we do a lot of the
magic that we do here's some examples of
the third party filters have been
created for Cordo lightbox for HTML
documents uh thing for showing proteins
and trajectories with molestar social
sharing buttons kind of any feature you
can imagine you can actually build a
filter for it and extend the system
um lots of different ways to write
filters there's two python libraries one
by the creator of pandok and then pans
with the one I showed it's kind of got a
little bit better API and more batteries
included pandok itself includes an
embedded blue interpreter so you can
create very fast zero dependency filters
and then you can actually write filters
in any language through Json
representation
um and we sort of have an extension
mechanism where you can publish and
reuse fill not just filters but also
short codes which are sort of a special
variant of filters that's like a Content
generating macro you can build custom
formats so some of the stuff I showed
you before dacosaurus and uh and
Confluence and things were sort of built
using our custom format mechanism you
can add plugins Google JS and also kind
of templates for different types of
projects so lots and lots of ways to to
build extensions and lots of attention
available
we actually have integration with nbdev
and
for those of you who don't know about
Envy Dev it's actually a way of
developing python packages entirely
within Jupiter and it kind of
automatically creates you know
CI for running their tests uh it
automatically gets your package or
creates gives you the code to publish
your package to Pi Pi and uh conda and
also generates a website containing the
documentation of your package and in
version two of Envy Dev uh Port of is
used to generate that website so it's
kind of also because Gordo is a open
source command line tool and very
customizable uh it's it's very easy to
sort of integrate with other tool chains
that you might be
so that's my talk um thanks very much
and hopefully folks have got some
questions and I'd love to hear them
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
um so I do have a vlog in Hugo and I use
notebooks quite often yeah so that
sounds really interesting but it seemed
odd to me that you would put in the
metadata in the notebook that the output
format this Hugo it seems that would be
a Hugo configuration thing to say render
yeah in the case of Hugo you you don't
if you put a notebook in it you go site
it just knows to rent to rent to use the
Hugo format the project mechanism
essentially creates like a format an
inheritance thing where it's a it's a
Hugo project so a notebook that's not
otherwise specified will rendered and
does Hugo use quarter by default or is
it no you you basically add it so you
just add notebooks to your Hugo and then
you say quarto you know quarto preview
or quarter lender and then it makes sure
that the notebooks are rendered and then
Hugo Picks Them Up in
um
thanks uh if we already have a website
that's run on Google and uh just like
you know apps on uh so that would work
you can do you can completely do that
yeah it'll just go it'll just go right
in there exactly yeah and uh graphics
and the pictures and stuff we'll put it
in the static they will you know yeah so
what it does it uses a feature of cubic
on page bundles page bundles is where
you put a an article or post in its own
directory and when with an index.nd
when you do that it actually copies the
whole directory into static for you so
you don't have to coordinate you know
over at assets yeah
but do you have any features associated
with processing transfusions
I don't think so
um
uh over here
a question about
um about which uh article formats are
supported on Porto yep
um are they are they mostly the high
impact ones like uh nature yeah so the
the there's a thing there's an again a
board called Porto journals where we
basically created a bunch of we probably
got a dozen or so
um I I think Nature's in there it's it's
we did five or six and then we get
community contributed another six or
seven and that will grow over time
um and it is not difficult to create
your own a lot of times users to decide
they want to publish to a journal with
Porto and then they just make the
template and based on like the journals
latex template
um so
um anyone you want to be supported can
be supported some of them are already
there and some of
has there been any
um have there actually been any tour
developed uh to convert a lot Tech to
Porto
well you can so pandok can read and
parse latte and create markdown from it
it's obviously not going to be able to
take completely arbitrary logic and
always do the right thing but for basic
things basic formatting tables headings
structure it can convert yes it can
convert that into the market
and um and even tame notoriously
horrible latte tables
maybe I don't know uh it it has a table
parser the the developers of pandok are
very sophisticated about law Tech and so
I don't know how good the table parser
is but I know they work hard at it
all right thank you
okay I'm sorry we're out of time let's
give a big round of applause
[Applause]
foreign